no it's not the spider-man no way home
trailer as
i'm sure many comments on the actual
trailer are saying right now but it's
shocking the legend of the 10 rings
another new trailer which of course of
course
we are so excited for asian
representation
baby pinoy pride even though i'm not
sure if there's any real filipinos in
this movie but i'm going to act like
there is any way
guys i want to say thank you to everyone
who watched my interview with uh margot
robbie and
david dasmalkian those are so
overwhelmed by the love they thank you
guys so much would it be in the position
if it wasn't for all of you but that's
dc why are you guys talking about it
because it's awesome
coexist in our fandoms geez it's okay
[Applause]
marvel body shots
oh
so cool
[Applause]
some new glimpses in here throughout a
lot of it is a similar or familiar
marvel body shot
love how sami lou is actually like an
insane martial artist
and but it's like the other marvel
actors were like so
insanely jazzed so insanely jacked and
buff
he it kind of reminds me of when i saw
like keanu reeves without his shirt on
and john wick i'm like man you're like
the most lethal dude but you don't rely
on being the most
cut person in the world like he's cut
like you're he's good you're definitely
fit but yeah you can start obnoxiously
you're not sitting there going what's
going to define
my muscles the most yeah the mirror yeah
i mean he's got to be agile it's gotta
be loose he's gonna be fast
right i loved it but yeah you can
actually get a lot of new shots here of
as we're coming through this you get a
lot of new shots here of the mandarin at
sea like you're seeing a little bit more
of how the rings actually operate like
it seems like
they move around in this like almost
aerodynamic fluid
fashion it's like in that last shot you
see him like oh
i don't really know what's going on in
that ending moment where the rings are
circling
shang chi maybe that is the final moment
where it's like fine let's battle for
the ten rings
you want to be a freaking arrogant son
about it fine let's go
let's go because i i don't think that
the mandarin
really wants to hand off the tent why
would the mandarin actually want to
hand off the 10 rings he's got to have
something sneaky going on he's gotta
have something where
he really has another trick up his ten
ring carrying sleeves
yeah yeah exactly his exposed arms but
underneath the tent rings is where this
yeah there's that one
shot where they're all facing the the
lake and the sort of wall on the other
side and i think on one of warren's most
recent shangshi videos warren cosmic
wonder warren our
our only channel that we cover on this
channel except for right now
we're covering the stevie's butt um but
he seemed to think that maybe part of
what the mandarin's plan might be is to
bring in
shanxi because he might be the key to
unlocking like the ancient city or
something like that you know his mom
who we don't really see much of in this
ad but you know like she's a mystic
and there's all that stuff in the
previous trailer about like his destiny
and whatnot so maybe yeah it's like
he's not trying to bring him in for the
family business maybe he's trying to use
him to get to an even greater source of
power
i mean that would just make the mandarin
that much more villainous
of like he really has no care for his
son at all
yeah he's just trying to use his son's
abilities in order to unlock
something greater for him to reap the
benefits of
yeah and if you want to be a part of it
with me that's cool but i'm not trying
to hand this off to you or anything
well i wonder if in that shot like maybe
in order to work where you're talking
about where to cross
that's where because it's not the dragon
finn fang
according to what a lot of comments were
saying the great protect the great
protector
obviously the dragon is admit bare
minimum
inspired by finn fangboom all right i
think we can all get on board with that
and so i'm wondering if that's part of
the challenge to get across the water
at some point in the movie he will have
to level up or attain
skills or maybe find the bravado within
him the courage within him to face the
dragon underneath the water and
but the the water is guarded like in
order to cross it you got to
defeat the dragon yeah the great
protector of the ancients
this lake shot has given us so much to
think about
the train really is yeah of course you
can imply i mean that's the fun part is
you go in and now that yeah you're
seeing
also a lot of scenes from the previous
full trailer just
expanded upon with a few more shots like
yeah you can start to
infer how they link together i feel like
our plot theories are
are mainly based off of you know actual
like structure and plot execution and
we're not going over like those
far-fetched
series i think what we're saying makes
sense and it could
actually line up with what's going on in
the film i did like getting another line
from aquafina
because i don't really feel like in the
other trailers they really showcase her
personality all that much you know
aquafina is
she alfred is a great actress actually
yeah she's a wonderful actress and she's
hilarious
you're giving her the right role and it
really does seem like you know actually
looking at this shot again of him he is
pretty cut back damn those arms are
pretty big
he's definitely working out he's just
not necessarily focused on the aesthetic
look of it only
i'm wondering who all these people are
that are because the tournament
sounded so secretive right and i thought
it would be a little bit more along the
lines of
like an enter the dragon kind of
tournament where it's only like
martial artist and exclusive but when
you look in the background here
you see all these people here in like
business suits some people losing like
casual attenders they're all like
you know doing like dealing with the
money
yeah you know this is how the mandarin
makes money i don't know if that's like
the actual tournament because then you
got like the different landscapes like
for example the final shot where he is
fighting with um the mandarin at the
very end which does not look like the
kind of event where people would
actually this looks like it's probably
that ancient city that the manor was
trying to unlock and then uh
shang chi has to take him on yeah so i
don't know if like this
this final fight is post-tournament the
other part is maybe a thing where like
underground criminals get access to to
that as well
yeah i was wondering about that maybe
there is something where like that
isn't the main tournament of the movie
or something like that like yeah maybe
it is like a lower
level tournament that's open to people
like abomination
yeah maybe it is a place where that like
the criminal underworld comes to watch
people of all varieties powered or not
deck each other out
but yeah guys this was a really cool
trailer guys what did you think about
this leave your thoughts down below
subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
want to shout some people who are
pledged to uh one of our higher tiers
over our patreon
joanna saint louis matthew mensing
sj94 justin
martin kayla watters
rosie bitey door fiora is a 66
ruby dynamite
colin philip j smith jr
smith comma jen milani lovelink
brittany bierly nietly doran
irwin roger chase gardner
tiana h hey madras dakova
i think i've discovered in this shout
out that this is where all of her female
subscribers
are yeah all of them all 15 of them are
here
and they want their names acknowledged
this is the most
woman we've ever shouted out this is
awesome yeah you are the entire
demographic of females who watch this
channel and we really really appreciate
you
thank you to all and some of you have
been pledged to our patreon here
for such a long time and some of you
guys are new
either way i really do appreciate the
support immensely
much love to all of you uh wouldn't be
here today if it wasn't for you guys so
thank you
[Music]
you